I think I have the single I I'm I
literally think I have one of the best
ideas for a social network I really
think it's the best idea I want to start
a social network that only lets you post
you got your perspective YouTube what's
up so so grateful that you clicked and
you're about to watch a new YouTube
video but before you do to one two nine
three one five seven three one that is
my texting community platform doing a
lot of one-on-one engagement in there
and also access opportunity first looks
in that environment to one two nine
thirty one five seven three one join it
now and now to the video you've been
wanting to watch
we have to change the conversation in
our society until this society puts
happiness as the North Star of success
not money we will continue to not be
happy deep down I don't hate trying to
win I hate knowing that I know tons of
millionaires who are borderline suicidal
I hate to know that it doesn't solve
[ __ ]
my favorite I'll rather cry in my
Ferrari are you a [ __ ] idiot crying
is not interested in any [ __ ] vehicle
it's far more happy it's far more
exciting to be happy taking the [ __ ]
bus we have to reform the conversation
in our society period
[Music]
yep tick-tock and LinkedIn you've heard
me say it over and over for last three
months
for everybody here who's b2b I can't
push you enough on LinkedIn I can't it's
just a big deal Instagram is now
favoring images over video very recent
change that's why they're seeing more
quotes and cartoons for me and a little
less video this is back to you know some
where I keep pushing this like watch
what I'm doing not what I'm saying it's
the first time I'm saying it publicly
and this is not super public but you're
not caught it but like like if I mean
it's hardcore to like really look at how
many times does he post video versus
pictures in the last two hundred days
that's some real tedious work but it's
all there my big hope just to make it
competitive is that tik-tok adds
pictures I think that's the big thing
sitting available will tick-tock do the
reverse of what Instagram did to
snapchat because Instagram is already
testing a tick-tock competitor in Brazil
right now right this second I want
tick-tock to do to do the reverse move I
think if tick-tock adds pictures I think
you've got a real fight that'll be fun
to watch I like mega fights let me tell
you why for everybody tick-tock matters
whether tick-tock hits your demo whether
tick-tock disappears like vine it's
completely irrelevant the skill set of
communicating in that format will map
somewhere else if instagrams this is why
everybody who pissed on snapchat and
didn't do it and then stories came for
Instagram and they all hit me up and
said see Gary [ __ ] glad I didn't
listen to you and waste my time the last
two years on snapchat I'm like really
because guess what you still have no
skill set on how to do Instagram stories
and now it really [ __ ] matters and
you would have learned the ability how
to create in a stories environment on
snap that you have transferred everybody
has to learn why tick tock is resonating
because every one of those people 12 to
20 are going to be your customer in 11
years and the format in which they would
like to be sold your product is going to
have way more nuances in the way that
they were built by loving tick MTV every
single business man and woman in their
40s dresses the way they do now because
of hip-hop culture if you didn't believe
in hip hop in 1985 six seven eight nine
you left a lot of understanding consumer
behavior the MTV hip hop nuances are now
the establishment the way that tick tock
creates and communicates in a decade or
two will be an establishment of
communication right it's an interesting
point right it's something that I don't
see anyone tell fluency that's cooked
thank you that's a great way to put it
like that that's the point that's why
that's why I became me because I was
never scared to go on social cam which
was hot for seven months which became
the beginning of me understanding
dailybooth you remember dailybooth
which was a laptop version of a selfie a
day which then became instagram which
they liked it's the skill set of being a
communicator
[Laughter]
[Music]
period I can give you the hacks I'm
telling you right now I can give me the
[ __ ] hacks I can give you the decks I
can give you the details you can just
copy everything I'm doing the problem is
what are you gonna put in there I can
tell you where to post and how I can
tell you like I'll tell you right now
that tick tock and LinkedIn are so under
priced with their organic reach that you
should be posting on there because you
will learn how to communicate in a
modern world tick tock or you will get
so much awareness you can have no
LinkedIn account go home from this
conference create one post a post write
four sentences on your thoughts about
you your business whatever and get way
more people seeing that than you could
ever imagine you can't do that on
Instagram anymore it's mature you can't
do that on Twitter anymore it's mature
there is no making the first video on
YouTube and getting 4,000 people to just
see it like the organic nature of
average content because actually
ironically with YouTube if you make some
fire you can have your first I mean
there's some gal I think I've just got
two million subscribers on the two
videos but I'm talking average content
you can put mundane simple content on
LinkedIn and tick-tock right now and get
enormous organic reach I was the
beneficiary of this on Twitter on
YouTube on to the house I've lived this
people will get repeat how much [ __ ]
investments you haven't picked up zero
dick goose nothing the biggest ROI for
me is being historically correct I'm
gonna give two bucks if any of you
[ __ ] go on tick-tock I care about
documenting it when it's true proven to
be true period I want to be historically
correct would I love that everybody in
here to do it of course I want to get
your email in three weeks saying how the
[ __ ] did you know I want you to win
there's so much abundance all of you
winning isn't gonna take away from my
views I want you to win and I want to
give me the device for free over and
over and over again
like I've been doing for the last night
help me
Birmingham help me help me understand
when it's free and consistent and
consistent and free and then because you
get older
you've been proven to be right and right
and right and yet for all the hands that
just went up
none of them are posting 45 50 times a
day I mean this is what got me to
mindset I'm like right
I can't it's not just taking the horse
and bringing it to the water and getting
it to drink it it's also talking to the
horse about their [ __ ] up dad
it's about a horse I get it like we need
to go there it you need to act listen
you want to get real ROI from this
conference go home and ask yourself why
are you not posting on every platform
every day you don't have time [ __ ] you
you didn't grow up with it you're not
you sweet you didn't grow up with it you
didn't grow up driving you [ __ ]
figured it out tell me help me
understand why what it takes too long to
get your makeup right and the lighting
how about don't worry about your makeup
and when somebody says you look like
[ __ ] reply to them go [ __ ] yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanted to start a club back to the
club idea I had this idea that was a mix
of Soho House and nightlife I was like I
want to start a club this was a really
interesting idea I'm curious to see how
you guys think about this
I'll give you an idea of how I think
about innovating where the culture is
right now I want to start a club called
Tuesday and it opens at 6:00 a.m. and
you walk in and you can't leave until 6
a.m. Wednesday you can't leave you can't
leave because that's the club like if
you ever leave you're never allowed to
come back yeah yeah they're like I basic
I basically I want to make it super
restrictive think about everybody here
so I'm gonna give up my I mean giving up
your entire to's that's absurd it's a
complete brain [ __ ] which is exactly why
I think it would work here's why would
work what and just see I'm curious like
here's how I always think I really I
hate focus groups of one but I feel like
I'm almost you see it's funny have you
here where you said something I'm
probably gonna start you
I feel like number one thing I push
against don't be a focus group of 1 I
wouldn't do that that doesn't mean
anything on the flip side I'm almost
wondering if I don't have any feelings
left if I'm so detached and letting it
run through me that when I think I'm
thinking at scale of consumer when I
come up with ideas that say make me go
this if if Tom and I were hanging now if
this was exactly happening I never
thought of that and we're just hanging
and he's like hey by the way did you
hear about Tuesday I'm like no he's like
there's a [ __ ] Club that opened in
New York or in LA that it's called
Tuesday I'm like what is it you walk in
at 6:00 a.m. it's like a Soho House
there's rooms and showers for people
whatever and you can't leave until
Wednesday oh I feel like that's [ __ ]
amazing here's why it's really amazing I
think one of the most interesting things
I've ever seen in my life
is when people go on collective business
trips or other kinds of trips if this
crew went for a week to wine country in
Spain and spent all our time together
the relationships are uncommon I am
still missing you love this de rock I
still friends with kids I went to
college with that guy I went to a Hood
College lobbies kids got kicked out of
school one of my friends that I talked
to today today got kicked out of school
seven weeks after our freshman year I'm
still friends with him I've always
thought that the first month of college
is this crazy thing that people make
true lifelong friends in the first 30
days of their freshman year in college
you if you surveyed a lot you'd be
stunned how many people have and I think
it's this big shift
it's said spending a ton of time I made
some real friends and had some real
moments on this Australia trip it took
for 17 days that I mentioned to a lot of
you buying wine in 2002 at South by
Southwest just two three days and the
evenings with get guys and gals jamming
so I want to force that I think that you
come into the club on Tuesday at six I
don't think people realize what 24 hours
actually could look like if you're
captive what it means for you know I
think a lot of people go to Soho House
and clubs and golf and do a ton of
things to network but you're there for
an hour and a half and it's with it's
not depth I think you walk in and you
know you're [ __ ]
you like scheduled area and it's also
very destructive like it's very
disruptive it's kind of how I brought up
February 2 today right notice how
February's second notice how mine's
Tuesday same theme can't [ __ ] up Monday
too much stress I'm gonna go to Tuesday
right and I think I don't know I really
it's cool right if there's some I
haven't been able to let this idea go
I've been sitting on it for a while now
I know always it's the same idea as I I
think I have the single I I'm I
literally think I have one of the best
ideas for a social network and I'm
disappointed and intrigued by the fact
one it's yeah I'm shared it it's
literally the best
it's literally I think I really think
it's the best idea I want a sort of
social network that only lets you post
once every 24 hours
that's the restriction the quality of
that content I think is extraordinary
you're stuck if I'm gonna say happy
birthday to Tom that's a grand by the
way the depth of the content if on my if
I'm stuck every 24 hours and it becomes
Instagram
I decide that tweet that that whatever
okay
it is happy birthday tom-toms that's way
bigger than writing him a letter he's
like holy [ __ ] right like the yeah gift
360 by post a year the quality would be
[ __ ] bonkers I think people would
really like it I think it would really
really work yeah just gave cached to a
digital item
yeah you just which is what we all want
and like by the way I would follow a
thousand more people right well like I'm
both sides what I would put out I
understand and I'd be like and then I
went you know when I was i dating this
seven years ago uh I was like oh and I
would probably follow snoop I don't
really give a [ __ ] about snoop all that
much but [ __ ] it one time a day like
he's probably intriguing and I think it
would become everybody's biggest
platform based on like how I can feel my
chemicals think about this
this back to the world is abundant like
you can only get to so many things so
I'm just like really passionate about
sharing my best ideas and like I mean if
I'm right about that that's a trillion
dollar idea
that's not we're not talking about a
million bucks on that one
[Music]